[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to Planet
coaster and welcome back to the aerobats
of Arabia
I just realized that I put the in front
of a coaster name which is I think the
cardinal sin of theme park enthusiasts
well it doesn't matter this is my ride
anyway so I don't think that should be a
problem now this is going to be a very
long episode as you can probably tell by
the time in YouTube at this point and
for me it kind of feels like it's three
episodes in one so I put some time
stamps in the description because I
split this video into different chapters
just as I did the last two videos but
for this one particularly I think it's
probably helpful to find a way to watch
this video in different parts or at
different times at your own Leisure as
well because it's uh it's a bit of a
long one I'm also trying to strap myself
in right now and get ready for uh doing
a commentary session of trying to talk
constantly for 45 minutes which I swear
I'm gonna try not to do too often
anymore because it is quite something
but it's all it's all for good because I
think and that good cause is getting a
single coherent video because I try not
to split my videos too much based on
time or things like that but really try
and give each video One focal point and
the focal point of this video is the
station building which for the for these
coasters is just an insanely complicated
and huge task so it is what it is now
the first part of this video is about
the interior of the station the second
part is about the exterior and the final
part is about a scene in front of it
which provides some context to what the
station is going to look like in its
final form so yeah I think these are
three parts that kind of thematically
make sense and from a gameplay
perspective they're also pretty uh well
purposefully placed I would say
normally I noticed I would do Interiors
of buildings after I've already done the
exterior and to be completely honest
it's because I just enjoy doing
exteriors more I think I'm better at it
as well I'm not that good at Interiors
but for this coaster I'm gonna make an
exception and start with the interior of
the station first because I think the
interior is by far the biggest challenge
at least in terms of how this is all
gonna work and how I'm gonna compose
this interior part because
this is a huge station and it's very
weird in terms of where paths and the
coasters are going because first of all
we have two coasters obviously but you
know there are dueling coasters with
station
um but I don't think there are any
dueling coasters in the world uh which
are of the SNS free fly type with their
huge wide carriages in fact I don't even
think there are dueling Wing coasters or
four-dimensional coasters in the world
there aren't but it's all gonna result
in a pretty complicated station because
you have these really wide trains so the
tracks have to be placed very far apart
and on top of that you need eight exits
and entrances in total because you need
one exit and entrance for each uh half
of each ride so that's just uh that's
that's a lot of paths going everywhere
and you need to find a way to make those
go either over or underneath the station
as well so yeah this is a this is a bit
of a huge thing this station is going to
to be about as large as some show
buildings for dark rides are which is
absolutely nuts and
um I it kind of took me a while to
figure out how to make this station work
thematically because having such a huge
space and making it look like a decent
interior of a building
um seemed like a little bit of a
challenge I wasn't really sure how to
approach this for a while but my biggest
inspiration at some point became Flying
Dutchman in afterlink which I know it
doesn't really make any sense because
it's a completely different theme but no
the inspiration was basically that I
don't have to make this look like an
interior of a building per se because it
would be kind of difficult to make this
one giant haul of some sort of decorated
Palace interior which would be the
preferred theme of this station because
you know we're talking about a ride
where we have a caliph and there's
physio going on a magical journey so
starting out in the palace grounds
definitely seem like the right thematic
way to approach this also gives the ride
its proper story where you start off in
the palace and then you start making
your way through the town ideally at
some point at the end of the ride we'll
enter some ruins and kind of go into
some dark and underground Parts before
we move back into the into the palace
but you know that's that's a story for a
later date when I try to cover the the
plot line of this coaster and its Dark
Ride sections but yeah I wanted this
station area to feel like the palace but
at the same time creating this huge
hallway
it would well for one be very difficult
to steam uh but I also think it would be
hard to make it look nice it would just
be one giant rectangular box and I
wasn't really looking forward to that So
eventually I came up with the idea why
not just make this look like the inner
Courtyard of a palace there are lots of
palaces in modern-day Iran and the
general area so I looked up many
pictures and you'll often find very
typical inner Courtyards with beautiful
Persian Gardens and all the like I'm not
going to get into gardening in this
video in the station here but I think it
is pretty cool especially the way that
they have these arcades of pillars and
arches around these Central Gardens so
that kind of turned into the inspiration
for this station so we have two
Courtyards with these galleries these
arcades on the sides and you come in
through these galleries over here you
can see one entrance you can see another
one and then you have the two entrances
ends of the queues on the other side by
the way
I'm using a little bit of suspensive
disbelief over here because obviously in
Planet coaster we only have one queue
per ride which is very strange I have no
idea how this works but it makes it a
little bit difficult to make a realistic
cue for writes like this because in
Planet coaster if you look at it guests
are gonna have to walk over the coastal
track or through the ride vehicles to
get to the other side because there's no
queue on the other side well looking at
a coaster like this you can very easily
tell that there's no way to get around
the other side of the coaster so that
doesn't really make any sense but you
know I'm just gonna build like I have
two entrances on either sides of these
coasters so you come in through these
Galleries and you'll leave through these
galleries as well and then these Open
Spaces right between the pillars are
just enough space for these wide
Vehicles as well as the uh the places
where you stand in line to board the
vehicle where you have the gates and
stuff so all of the fence work is neatly
Within These plazas and then the coaster
as well which works out pretty neatly I
think and then another thing that kind
of annoyed me at first about this this
whole ordeal was the fact that these
coasters are so wide I had to make huge
arches to actually allow these coasters
to go into the dark ride section but
come think of it now I think these
arches actually look pretty cool and
they provide a nice uh a nice change
from the monotony of the uh of the
galleries otherwise and they were a
pretty fun thing to try and decorate as
well so I think all together it it's a
pretty cool Courtyard looking area and
just like the The Flying Dutchman
station I'm trying to make this thing
look like it's night time as well so it
could just be you know an open air
Courtyard but inside here it's it's just
night time so we've got lots of Lights
um and I'm trying to make the ceiling as
invisible as possible which
realistically you're never going to be
able to achieve and I think the same is
true for for the Flying Dutchman I
always remember looking up at the
ceiling there and just realizing that
you're in a giant Warehouse well the
same goes for this building but I think
especially with all of these galleries
around here with their details and their
lanterns not too much of your attention
should go to the ceiling anyway so I
think it's a it's a decent way to
approach this and now I'm getting to
some of the lighting challenges of this
area because obviously I'm gonna have to
light all of this
um by hand and I think this is uh this
is a nice way to also work around the
problem in Planet coaster that Interiors
don't really look that great when
there's no natural light coming in
because light just goes straight through
walls because walls don't create dark
places they just uh cast Shadows so this
is also a nice way to get around that
restriction in Planet coaster to make it
nighttime inside the station building
anyway
by the way I decided to play some fences
on this side of the track because well
the game doesn't provide them for us
because there's no entrance there but I
did want to realistically make it look
like that would be an entrance on that
side as well so hopefully it looks like
people can kind of get in there from at
least the coaster and walking around in
the station and then also good to note
is that we have a loading and an
unloading space so we have the wide open
area at the front of the station where
people load and then at the back where
people can unload as well that said
let's move to the exterior foreign
to me trying to tackle the challenge of
covering up this giant gray box that
I've now built with the station interior
in it and something that I'm going to
mention straight away is that I
struggled a lot with how to make the
parts for the queue actually work out so
as you can see I've worked out some
different routes for the queue lines we
have two queue lines right at the start
here which is just something that I have
to deal with because that's how the game
works ideally also I would have one
queue line and then you'd split it up
into different segments once you get
close to the station but in this case
there's no way to get around the fact
that I have to have two queue lines or
you know
I could have just built a normal path
into the building but then you would
have people walking back and forth which
would also be a little bit weird so in
the end I opted for this solution and at
some point when I get to detailing the
queue line I'm gonna make sure that it
does look like you can jump from one q
line to the other at least so it doesn't
look too weird or we have some hallways
where they share a hot to share a
hallway so it kind of looks like it's
some kind of single queue line but this
is something I'm gonna have to deal with
and also I have some routes planned for
some back and forths not really any
Kettle pens but definitely some kind of
q line layouts right underneath the dark
right section of the coaster
and also you're going straight
underneath the station at the start here
and that's something that I've been
unsure of doing for a while because
the exterior of this station is going to
resemble a mosque and musks don't
typically have layouts like this in fact
musks are very strictly laid out in real
life also with certain elements also
pointing towards Mecca because well
that's there uh that's what musks are
really for
um so inevitably I think if you're
trying to use that design language in a
theme park you're going to lose some
religious meaning there in this case it
means that although this building
resembles a mosque on the outside it's
not going to resemble a musk on the
inside and instead the queue lines are
gonna wind their way through some
catacombs and some Palace hallways and
rooms and stuff like that and maybe even
an inner Courtyard here and there with
some Gardens although that's still
something that I'm trying to plan in the
background and still working out what it
is exactly that I want
but that said I was considering for a
while to make this building look like a
palace building like like a main Palace
building from the outside for a while
but eventually I opted against it simply
because a mosque just looks way cooler
with the domes and the minarets and
stuff like that and I think that's the
kind of architectural language that
people are looking for in an Arabian
part of a theme park so that's what I
ended up going with but I am still using
a lot of the design language of a mosque
so the first part of the building that
I'm working on here is what is called
the E1 and I'm gonna have to give a
disclaimer for most of these things I
only know about this because I did a
bunch of research before I started
building this but I'm not an expert on
this topic and definitely not very good
at pronouncing all of the words then or
at least some of the words I'm going to
say but basically an E1 is an open sort
of front area where with with three
enclosed sides and then a sort of half
created interior dome and it's something
that you'll find on many Persian mosques
in Modern Day Iran I think a
particularly cool example is an Isfahan
Square which is I believe to be a UNESCO
world heritage square which has a bunch
of musks and a palace on different ends
and it's it's a beautiful square with
completely
um symmetrical elements to it as well
which is really cool and kind of inspire
higher the look of this building as well
as some of the future buildings around
it in the future but yeah working on
this E1 over here is a little bit
different than they would be in real
life often in real life you'll find that
these areas have kind of honeycomb like
decorations at the at the vaulted roof
but in this case I really couldn't
figure out how to make that look
anywhere near decent in Planet coaster
so I opted to go with the decorations
then I just placed over there right now
but to be honest this interior of at
least this part is perhaps subject to
change at some point in the future if I
figure out how to make it look a little
bit more like I the way I want it
because I'm not completely happy with
how this works
but I am pretty happy with though is uh
the theme makers toolkit items that I'm
using around here uh I put the Pearl
tile wall sets which actually are
pillars I think
um to use as these kind of
man I hate it when I get called during a
recording but yeah basically I'm using
these Pearl tiles as some kind of glazed
tile work which is something that you'll
very often find on musks like this and
then there are also all kinds of
decorations and calligraphy that can be
found on the exteriors which you know in
the complete details there isn't really
much in Planet coaster or the theme
makers toolkit which resemble these
things but I found a way that kind of
makes it work which is to put rugs on
the sides of these walls and still get
some of those decorations in and I think
given the context of the fact that
they're on walls and surrounded by these
tile pillars and everything
um they don't really look like they're
just rocks on walls but actually
resemble some cool decorative patterns
so honestly I was I was pretty happy
with that idea
um maybe at some point in the future
I'll actually start using the rugs as
the rugs but who am I to start using
objects for their intended purposes in
games like these
um I've never really been a fan of that
anyway so this mosque has that kind of
huge entrance at the front and then some
setbacks at later stages and there's
also a little bit of you guessed it
forced perspective in here as well so as
you can see I'm placing some
small-ish windows on these top floors
and I say small-ish because they're
still pretty large but compared to the
ground floor that floor is actually much
smaller so that means that I have to
make arches all over again for the
bottom floor
so actually I haven't really given this
a thought yet but I am making so many
custom arches in this episode It's
actually kind of crazy but this is going
to be the slightly larger Arch which
creates that sort of forced perspective
idea obviously it's much bigger than the
ones at the top uh but it still helps to
create that layering where the top is
set back a little bit and a little bit
smaller and hopefully makes the whole
building stand out a bit more and appear
even larger than it already is because
to be honest this is a pretty large
building but I still want to make it
look much larger while at the same time
I'm trying to hide these interiors and
make them look as small as possible it's
all a little bit of a complicated puzzle
I suppose also I have to say I haven't
talked about this yet but these path
covers that I'm using are made by mango
which are really cool so shout out to
him for these uh I kind of wish there
was more to this set because it's one of
those things where I have to keep mixing
and matching stuff to make them actually
work as part covers of sidewalks because
they're actually meant for small parts
that go through little gardens or Parks
but I think it works if you put enough
of them together and now it's time to
also put some path covers in between
them
and man does it always feel like I'm
playing Roller Coaster Tycoon 3 whenever
I try to puzzle path covers over
existing path textures I think that's
something that people
started doing in Planet coaster only a
while after Planet coaster was long a
thing because it's something that takes
a lot of effort but I feel like the more
years you play Planet coaster and the
more you see those in-game standard part
covers the more they kind of start
annoying you as well so I like coming up
with custom ways to make these things as
well
so that also means some sidewalk
elements some curbs if you can call them
that and of course some Shrubbery in
front of the entrance
that said I'm not going to build a sign
for this entrance anytime soon because
I'm still not 100 sure if I'm going to
keep this look for the entrance E1 or if
I'm going to change it at some point in
the future so for now see this as a
little bit of a work in progress it
might stay the same and then I'll just
add some letters in front of it and make
sure that this is very clearly the
entrance to the coaster but otherwise
it's just gonna you know be overhauled a
little bit at some point in the future
also some things that I think deserve a
shout is the bricks which are from the
theme makers toolkit as well which I'm
making the sides of these arches with
the the kind of beige-ish bricks which I
think works pretty well with the color
scheme to this color scheme in general
of the building has
um I think also generally a a three-way
strategy so we've got white for the
walls which is the base color and then
we have brown for
um everything from uh making sure where
different floors are to pillars to
cornerstones and stuff like that and
then we have a kind of turquoise color
for the details generally and this is
definitely a tip that I've said before
but I think it's it's never wrong to
repeat useful tips like this generally
it's good to choose three colors for a
building and with European buildings I
would typically choose one color for the
walls one color for detail cells which
includes doors and pillars and cornices
and stuff like that and a third color
for your roof but in a building like
this we don't really have a slanted roof
all we have is a dome at some point in
the future on top of this building which
is going to be a whole other thing so
for this building I have a a collar
scheme of three collars on the walls
um with the I think a pretty well fit
together
variation in it as well
now here I wanted to build the minarets
which are a very typical element on
musks of course and reading back on the
history of minarets a while ago I
discovered that they're actually partly
inspired by the churches the towers of
churches so there are definitely some
interesting religious links there and
really the purpose of a minaret is to to
make the general mosque a bit more
grandiose and Monumental and provide
that height to the building so they're
really kind of an aesthetic thing
typically and don't have as much
religious symbolism or meaning as some
other elements of a mosque if I remember
it correctly now these minarets are very
much inspired by a building which exists
in real life which is called uh and I'm
going to butcher this name for sure but
the Imam Hassan are ascari mosque in
Iran which from what I can tell is a
relatively recent mosque
um I couldn't find any information on
when it was first built and when its
current iteration was built but its
current iteration does look very new so
I'm gonna act off of that suspicion
alone supposedly it's a mosque which has
existed for many centuries
um but has recently got a very large
renovation that I believe is open in
2015 but all of that doesn't matter too
much I think it's a beautiful building
uh with a really cool detailing so these
minarets are a bit inspired by it as
well the thing that I like about the
building in real life is that they have
a Podium which looks a lot like the rest
of the building so here you can see that
the the tower that I'm building the
round minaret on top of is also square
and very similar to the rest of the
building and then once we get higher we
start moving into the round part of the
minarets and we start going even taller
also I came up with a sort of tiled a
glazed way to decorate these towers in a
sort of spiral pattern over here and for
a while I was also experimenting with
how to exactly make this pattern work
how to how tall to make these spiers and
stuff like that it was definitely try on
error but eventually I got there and I
have to say making that spiral it looks
really cool but it's really not that
impressive it's not that hard to do you
just create some stones on one floor
copy them over move them over rotate
them a little bit rinse and repeat so as
always with these kind of strategies you
can make some pretty cool looking stuff
in Planet coaster that looks harder to
pull off than it really is I'm not sure
if I'm going to use that trick anywhere
else but it was very much fun to try and
mess around with
and finally it is time for the last part
of this minarets you could just see me
use a blueprint real quick there which
fun fact is actually a blueprint from
shikra and all the unfinished Arabian
themed coaster that I worked on a long
time ago that perhaps maybe I'll finish
once this project is done because I'm
definitely getting a lot of experience
in making Arabian builds but we'll see
that's uh that's a story for another day
as well
um but I figured that the minute that I
need here is a little bit larger than
the one that I built for shikra but
something similar could work so for a
while I was trying to figure out how to
make the columns work and how to
actually give these columns the texture
of a real life column eventually I
figured you can always take a square
beam and rotate it around until you get
a round beam and then it also has that
column-esque texture that you typically
see for Roman columns and the likes so I
think that works out pretty well and
then it was just a bit of trial and
error to figure out which pieces were
just the right size to provide a uh to
provide the different decorations on
these pillars and then finally figure
out how large exactly this this top part
of the minaret should be in relation to
the rest of the building but eventually
I uh I suppose I figured it out I think
this works pretty well so this whole
build was really inspired on something
that I've built before except a little
bit larger this time and maybe with a
bit more detail and typically I feel
like when you're doing something again
especially after you've lost something
or it's been too long since you've
worked on something typically you get to
do it a little bit better at least in
this case I think I'm definitely
improving on the theme compared to what
I was doing when I was working on shikra
granted it's taking me a bit more time
as well a bit things are getting pretty
complicated at this point
but I'm pretty happy with how it's
turning out
and once we get to the top of the
minarets you can see after some trial
and error with some custom elements I
ended up just putting at the Maker's
toolkit Dome on top of this which I
don't think there's any shame in that
this Dome just looks really good and
there's no way to make anything like
that from the in-game pieces and after
some copying around the minarets are
finished so that was the minaret
definitely one of my favorite parts to
work on but probably my favorite part of
at least the exterior build of the
station is the large dome in the middle
of the mosque now this is obviously very
iconic for musks so I figured how can I
build a building like this and leave out
the Dome I really wanted to make this
something special as well
now the problem is making nice round
domes of a single column of a single
collar is pretty difficult in Planet
coaster because as nice as the
rotational trick is you're always going
to get some strange uh Parts clipping in
into each other and stuff like that and
with European domes you typically have
some elements that you can hide that
with but with Arabian domes or Persian
domes they tend to look different and
have different decorations which make it
a bit harder to hide those things so I
wanted to be very careful with the uh
the basic shapes that I'm using to
create this dome but as you can see I
think it's pretty flush the only thing
that happens is that the lighting that
reflects off the Dome you can definitely
see it be a little bit blocky but I'm
gonna try and hide that a little bit
with some of the other decorations on
this Dome
so staying with the spiral pattern of
the minarets I wanted to have a spiral
decoration pattern on this Dome as well
it's something that I found on many of
the musks that I researched to get ideas
for this so I figured it would be cool
to add it over here as well and when it
comes to the colors I'm just bringing
back some of the colors that you can see
Elsewhere on the building so the Dome
has a similar color as the glazed tiles
on the front of the building and on the
towers of the minarets
Minimates our Towers but you know what I
mean
um so we've got that color coming back
and then also the beige from the details
on the front facade and with all of that
I think this is a pretty cool Dome that
manages to work decently
the only thing that I couldn't figure
out for a while was how to make the
bottom of this Dome look okay-ish and
this is something that looking back at
it now I didn't have to put as much
effort into as I did at the time because
you're rarely ever gonna see this part
of the Dome because it's hidden behind
the front of the building the Dome is
quite far into the building so from most
parts of this area you're not going to
be able to see this part of the dome but
still I wanted to make something decent
looking there and that's it for the
exterior of the station and let's move
on now to the final part of this video
and work on the front of the station
[Music]
all right so the last part of this video
is going to be about this bridge and
also some surrounding areas around the
bridge now the reason that I wanted to
go for a bridge here is well first of
all the coaster is kind of going here I
have to get back into the station at
some point but also I didn't want the
kosu to block the view of that station
we couldn't have that so
the coaster is going right underneath
the parts here and I think it also
provides some nice Force perspective of
the station too because you have that
trench right in front of the building
and then you have the bridge going over
it I think it provides an extra sense of
scale to the station building
and on top of that I think it gives a
good excuse to have this wide open area
in front of the station with no other
buildings around it so that your eyes
can look at the one thing where I want
your eyes to look which is the station
with no other distractions
and this bridge over here is inspired by
one of the bridges crossing the river
well I say River but it's it's a
supposed River going through Tokyo
Disney sea in the Arabian Coast Area and
it's actually very similar to that down
to the way that I'm decorating it with
these large vertically placed bricks
that said it's a little bit more
Flats than that you can see there's a
very slight Arch to the bricks and it
has that slightly Arabian look to it but
that's that's enough said about that
because there's barely any Arch at all
it's just something I had to do given
the fact that these coasters aren't
going down too low in that trench and
that trench do be very wide because
these ride vehicles are very wide so
there are some logistical challenges all
around trying to marry this theme to The
coaster type that I chose at some point
in the past
but also it gives me some nice excuses
to add some decoration over here so
because this is such a large Bridge
there's more than enough space to add
some very large Planters on the side
with some decoration in it some flowers
some bushes and make this whole area
look a little bit more green because as
much as we are in the desert over here I
do want it to look very Lush we are in a
lush desert I think
um so that's uh that's something nice to
add to this as well
and then Finishing Touches for the
bridge itself of course are the typical
decorations the ways to make the
textures look just a little bit more
aged and add some Grime and stuff to it
I I'm still such a big fan of all of
those theme makers toolkit items
especially the grimy stuff it's really
amazing at just subtly changing some of
the textures in the game and making
everything look a little bit different
than what we're used to from this game
and finally I'm adding a little bit of
decoration on the inside of the tunnel
as well because obviously when you're
riding these coasters you're going to
see that too so
um I put some old uh castle-ish walls on
the side there and uh putting some
decoration on that as well but keeping
it minimalistic because obviously this
is not the most important part of this
whole area
fun fact also both of these coasters
reach their top speed right at the
bottom of these drops and I think the
way that this bridge is built also
provides a nice head chopper so that
this might be one of the most thrilling
moments of this ride even though it's
just a very simple drop and then you go
up again it does reach its top speed
it's pretty fast and you do come kind of
close to the top of that bridge so
hopefully that provides a sense of speed
also in my planning after this tunnel
The Coasters go into
well what I could call an airtime Hill
but there's not going to be a lot of air
time on it maybe it's going to be a
little bit floatery but after that
airtime Hill they once again they once
again start descending and they move
into the dark right section at the end
of this ride
which is something that I'll talk about
more in a future episode when I get to
that which I can already predict is
going to take a while because I want to
tackle this area of the Park first
around the coaster which I've already
built but at some point in the future
you know you're going to dip into that
tunnel really get a sense of speed move
up again and then uh once again crash
down into a dark ride section and in
that dark ride section is going to be
sort of the climax of The coaster As you
move through the old ruins that the
storks find before they find their
solution to their storkness but you know
once again I'm not going to spoil too
much of the story but uh the general
layouts of the ride should follow the
story as well so it's uh it's all part
of the plan I'd say
now something fun uh that I could
actually talk about in the meantime
while I've been adding all of these lamp
posts and foliage as you can see really
adding the touches that hopefully make
this area come to life a little bit uh
something fun I think to talk about is
uh the rock work which I've already done
a little bit of just now but which I'm
going to do a lot more of uh in a few
minutes
um because all of the rock work in this
area and almost all of the rock work of
this coaster is going to be made out of
a single Rock piece and you're gonna see
in a bit how that's gonna work maybe you
can already kind of see it come to life
on the sides of these Cliffs
um now I'm actually kind of regretting
saying this already because I was
wondering whether you guys already
noticed that I uh I placed those rocks
there and that they were all the same
Rook
oh well it doesn't matter too much
no actually notice I actually wonder
whether you guys notice things that I
show in my time lapses but don't talk
about because I don't find them too
interesting or I'm busy talking about
something else because obviously a lot
happens in these time lapses and while I
know of all these things I mean these
are recordings of me playing I typically
choose some of the more interesting
things to talk about and that won't be
everything that I'm doing
um so yeah pay attention I guess but
here I'm doing some of the some of the
last facade work on this side of the
show building of the Dark Ride area
which is not very special but it's
something that has to be done to fill in
the Gap with the musk part of the
building because also in real life these
buildings are all just a single building
the mosque these facades on the side
here are really all just a way to hide
the big gray box that is the station and
Dark Ride area
but I'm trying to give it as much
architectural diversity as possible on
the outside of course and try to make it
look as much as possible like they are
rows of different buildings uh for this
transition I couldn't really figure out
how to make it work very well it just
kind of swaps from cityscape to Giant
musk which is something that can happen
so for example the mosques in Isfahan
are also really embedded into an urban
Fabric and just to the north of the of
the largest mosque there is also a giant
Bazaar uh which is it's kind of bizarre
I've looked at it it's honestly pretty
cool I was thinking for a while to do
something like that over here as well
but I think it's completely undoable
um but yeah you have these musks kind of
working in the general Urban Fabric in
an interesting way which I really like
but in this case it's not really too
special it's just I'm connecting up
these facades even hiding it a little
bit with this palm tree I noticed and
some of the decorations around here not
that it matters too much I think
because well I'm going to place
something on this mid-course break run
or below this mid-course break run I
should say which is going to hide from
view most of these facades from
different areas of the park really those
facades up there are only for when
you're walking on that path between the
mosque and the other parts of this area
but there are not going to be any sight
lines over there which as always try to
focus most of your attention in your
detailing on areas where you know there
are going to be sight lines
so you don't put too much effort into
things that you don't end up seeing from
every perspective and you know stuff
like that plus it's just how theme parks
realistically work in real life very
often as well
now for this mid-course break run I
decided to put these things on top of
buildings
for a while I was considering actually
making them go through buildings which I
thought would be very interesting but I
realized it wouldn't really work uh due
to just the way that these coasters are
they're so wide it would be very hard to
make these go through buildings and not
make the buildings look very janky and
weird and like they have way too large
openings so instead I figured I might as
well just have these things go over the
roofs and then add some verticality to
it in another sense which I ended up
doing with these decorations these fence
uh kind of building wall roof
decorations hybrids not even exactly
sure what to call them but I I just kind
of figured they worked out pretty
alright
uh had to change the catwalks up a
little bit here to provide enough space
another thing which I ended up doing
here which I realized in hindsight
wasn't completely necessary but does
kind of help in the scaling of this
whole catwalk setup is the fact that I
had catwalks enabled on both coasters so
that I could tell just how large the
catwalk should be to provide enough
space for the carriages to swing around
while not making this building any
larger than it needs to be but you know
in hindsight I could just turn off the
catwalks at the end and what I ended up
doing is hiding the catwalks as much as
possible so I'm looking back at this
footage and thinking I did things in a
harder way than I should have but it
worked out in the end so I'm pretty
happy with it I'll take it
and then a final touch on that building
which I didn't discuss but which I think
makes a big difference is that Lamppost
in the middle
it looks a bit janky it looks a bit
weird but at least it provides a
vertical element for The Coasters to go
past and
um it's gonna work in the general area
of this of this park trust me at some
point it's all going to come together
but at this point some things might look
a bit random but I do have some plans
for things now is when we get to the
Rock work by the way which is going to
be
very interesting as you can tell I
started out with a layer a base layer I
would say just putting rocks down and
trying to get the shape of this hill
down as much as possible
for a while my idea was to have
waterfalls go underneath the coaster
track here
but then I figured
it wouldn't be very thematically
consistent to have waterfalls over here
as cool as it would be it's a little bit
weird I wouldn't expect it from this
kind of theme
So eventually I just stuck with the
Rocks over here and by placing a bunch
of rocks in different directions and
trying to rotate them around as much as
possible I think you can use a single
Rock to provide some interesting texture
and as you can see I also changed
changed some of the colors on some of
the Rocks a little bit to provide some
texture differences as well and that is
actually the explanation why I ended up
you know using this specific Rock
because you might be thinking why are
you sticking to this this single Rock
reason being is that the creator of this
Rock Box Doom shout out to them decided
to pull a little bit of a chat move on
this one and create what I think is one
of the best rocks on the theme makers
toolkit in Planet coaster
uh refused to elaborate and then leave
so this is the only rock that we got
from them and it's a pretty good rock so
I like to use it but there's only one of
them and the thing that makes me like
this rock even though it's just a single
Rock and it has a bit of an unwieldy
shape as well I must say is the fact
that you can recolor it in three
different colors and one of the colors
changes the highlights ish that's kind
of how it works one of the colors
changes the Shadows or some of the
darker parts of the of the rook and then
another color kind of changes the the
whole base color of the rock so you can
create endless Variety in terms of the
texture of this rock and I wish there
were more rocks with this kind of
texture approach the planet coaster
because it's a really clever way of
allowing users to create a realistic
natural looking rocks in various
different colors I remember Planet
coaster has
um realistic looking items that aren't
recolorable because as Frontier once
explained to me it's very difficult to
make recolorable items that have
realistic textures because once you make
an item recolorable everything just kind
of moves to a single color so for
example if you have a recolorable wooden
plank you make it red it turns red yes
but you kind of lose the the variation
in color that you usually have on the
blank and this approach with a single
realistic item with one color but three
recoloring options kind of gets around
that which is a really cool and clever
so shout out to this rock piece uh
anyway with that said with some final
decorations and some foliage to make
this area Lush and green we've come at
the end of this video so I'd like to
thank you guys for watching I hope you
enjoyed this uh interesting and lengthy
buildup of the station in its area and I
hope to see you guys in the next video
bye bye
foreign
[Music]